toujours plus cher les loyers parisiens
la chambre des notaires vient de le
confirmer dans une récente étude
l'an dernier le prix du mètre carré
tenez vous bien a augmenté de 18% dans
la capitale parallèlement le nombre des
transactions a chuté de 15 pour cent
pendant la même période alors que ces
cinq dernières années les prix de vente
des logements anciens à paris ont plus
que doublé la courbe de hausse marque en
effet un léger coup de franc 90 avec
seulement 17 points 5 % d'augmentation
après la flambée de plus 25% 88 mais en
moyenne l'achat d'un seul petit mètre
carré d'appartements s'élève tout de
même à plus de 22 mille francs si l'on
assiste aujourd'hui à une valorisation
des arrondissements les plus populaires
le clivage est ouest demeure les
seizièmes 8e et 6e arrondissements
remporté le palmarès mais surtout le 7e
où l'on ne trouve rien à moins de 37
mille francs le mètre carré au coeur de
paris le 4e et le 1er arrondissement
marque compte a eu une hausse des prix
de plus de 25% alors que dans le 9ème et
12ème arrondissement quartier autrefois
réputé abordable m² passe la barre des
22 mille francs reste quatre
arrondissements du nord et de l'est
parisien ainsi que le deuxième qui
atteignent tout de même les dix-huit
mille francs la guerre du golfe mais
aussi la pénurie relative qui
caractérise le marché parisien explique
en partie cette baisse de tension sur
les prix
en outre le volume de transaction
immobilière a chuté de 8% entre 89 et 90
enfin le fossé continue de s'élargir
entre les prix de paris et ceux de la
petite couronne
par mesure de comparaison il est encore
possible d'acheter pour 9000 francs le
mètre carré en seine saint denis